Okay, to check your understanding of
this, let me ask a couple questions.
First of all, what is the specifications
say if x is the empty vector?
>> So if x is the empty vector,
then y is also the empty vector.
They're equal.
>> Okay, they have the same elements.
Right?
And in fact,
there was a special case that
checked exactly that thing.
Okay?
Here's a little bit trickier one.
What happens if the first element
of X appears in more than one place
in the output.
>> I feel like we're still covered
because the way that we defined it.
We know that for this element that
does exist in x there's a place in y
that is also that element also exists.
>> There's at least one place.
>> At least.
>> At least one place and
the exists quantifier doesn't
care which one you've got.
>> Mm-hm
>> As long as you use that position
consistently.
If there is more than one occurrence
of x sub 1 in the output, okay.
Then when we do our recursive
permutation check on smaller and smaller
segments, we'll run into this situation
again and eventually we'll get down to
where we're comparing the empty vectors
which we'd say are our permutation.
>> Right.